So now that we understand how to
address the variety of screen sizes and
densities out there,
we can get into how we go about
constructing your user interface.
As you remember from
Android Fundamentals,
your UI is a nested tree that
we call the view hierarchy.
Now, this tree defines the entire
structure of the UI from the root view
group all the way down to the leaf
views, such as text, buttons, or images.
Now, every single thing you
see on the screen in your app
is a view somewhere in this hierarchy.
You can define your UI either by
creating these objects in code, or
by declaring your layout in an XML file.
Now we very much prefer
the latter approach,
as it allows you to separate the
presentation from the app's behavior.
Each element in your UI will have a
number of parameters associated with it.
Some are common and must be provided for
all views, such as its width, height, or
location on the screen.
Other parameters are specific to
a particular view, such as a button will
have parameters for its background and
the text to display.
Let's dive in and see how the elements
are sized and placed on the screen.